the post American world is a world in
which the United States can't assume
that when it will get whatever it wants
it can't assume that others will follow
its lead and I think that as you've seen
in the wake of the financial crisis and
in the wake of the American elections
the Obama administration basically can't
make its own policies without anybody
dissenting either at home or abroad the
Fed can't make its own choices about
monetary policy without having other
central banks and other political actors
outside the United States chime in and
these things are somewhat new and it'll
be hard for the United States and
Washington to get used to a world in
which it has to lead by persuasion and
example and competence rather than mere
assertion of dominance
you're right that the Republican Party
and many Americans frankly will be
opposed to this very concept but the
thing about reality is it's there
whether you like it or not and the post
American world is not a question of
American exceptionalism it's not a
question of how good we are or moral we
are it's not a question of whether we
deserve to be prominent or not prominent
it's a question of the basic fact that
power is now somewhat more widely
distributed particularly economic power
than it used to be and that we no longer
basically can get whatever we want and
so the American public is going to have
to adjust to this and grow up
essentially